[Music]
this is sky news it is one o'clock and
we're live in la viv with a special
program on the war in ukraine
another fatal shelling in kiev with the
mayor telling sky news that attacks on
civilians are deliberate
drone footage shows the damage after
parts of a missile fell on a residential
area in the capital
new pictures emerge from mario paul
showing the scale of the destruction as
it's confirmed 130 people have been
rescued from the bombed theater in the
city
but the russian ambassador to the u.n
insists his country is the victim of
fake news
we have this information which is raging
much much on on a much greater scale
than the than the battle dead on the
battlefield and i will not be surprised
at anything because
who wins the the information the one
wins the world
but a set back for moscow in that
information war as the broadcaster rt is
stripped of its uk licence
[Music]
well hello good afternoon we are here at
an aid distribution center in la viv in
western ukraine we'll show you around in
a bit but first of all let's bring you
up to date with today's top stories the
war is now in its 23rd day and there are
further signs that russia is filtering
its armed forces face ongoing logistical
challenges and the ukrainian resistance
shows no sign of relenting well the
advance on the capital and elsewhere has
stalled according to british and u.s
intelligence but that raises fears over
a change in tactics by vladimir putin as
more cities and civilians face increased
shelling
while the mayor of lev says several
missiles hit a facility used to repair
military aircraft but work there had
already been suspended a bus repair
facility was also damaged but there are
no reports of casualties so far
sky news has verified this video and
located it to a shopping mall in
mariupol the port city near the russian
border which has seen so much
devastation russia's defense ministry
says with the help of separatists in
eastern ukraine its forces are
tightening the noose around mario pole
and new footage has also emerged of the
bombed theater in that city where
thousands of civilians were sheltering
ukrainian officials say 130 people have
been rescued so far but there's still no
word on casualties
well russia's ambassador to the un
denies his country carried out the
attack hasseline lavenziel was pushed on
the issue by sky's martha kellner
look
what kind of atrocities are you
referring to i'm talking about narrow
trenches in mario paul with babies
bodies in i'm talking about theaters in
mario paul being bombed by russia
the theater in mariopol was not bombed
by russia
i spoke about it and you may refer to my
statement i do not know anything about
the trenches with
killed babies in it i haven't seen it ap
ap journalists have been there since so
many fakes uh we have this information
which is raging much much on a much
greater scale than the than the battle
dead on the battlefield and i will not
be surprised at anything because
who wins the the information the one
wins the world
and in donetsk at least four people have
been killed in shelling in that city
authorities in the self-proclaimed
people's republic say mortar rounds were
fired by ukrainian nationalists donetsk
is one of the two regions which has been
officially recognized as independent by
russia
so let's look at the other developments
in ukraine today then
ukraine's president vladimir zelensky
has warned foreign mercenaries
considering joining russian forces in
ukraine would be the worst decision of
their life
u.s president joe biden is due to speak
to the chinese president xi jinping
around about now and is expected to warn
him not to support russia's military
action
in the uk the homes for ukraine scheme
begins accepting applications from today
with ukrainian refugees who've matched
up with a sponsor in the uk
and as we heard ofcom has revoked the
license of the kremlin-backed
broadcaster rt with immediate effect
one more on that last development in
just a moment but first the british
ministry of defense
has said russia's progress here has
stalled this week and ukrainian forces
are continuing to frustrate putin's
attempts to encircle the capital kiev
but the armed forces minister james
heapey says attacks in western ukraine
are concerning
what's going on in mario paul is a cause
for huge concern the city is uh under a
level of barrage that is utterly
terrifying and disastrous for the
population that remains there the
ukrainian mps that visited me here in
the ministry of defense yesterday uh
were telling me that maybe 90 percent of
the city is is now being uh affected um
and as you say you know the there are
now two strikes into western ukraine the
air base last week and uh and strikes
november last night um so whilst there's
no macro progress
we're very concerned about the suffering
of the people in mario paul and other
cities that are under siege in the east
and the fact that ukrainian supply lines
are starting to be attacked in the west
well let's get an overview then of what
has been happening on the ground here
the russian advance has virtually
stopped but attacks continue on various
cities as we've heard missiles hit an
aircraft repair plant near here in lev
early this morning no casualties though
were reported this city is considered a
relative safe haven and gateway to
europe for the thousands fleeing the
wall
well russia's defence ministry said
today that their troops are tightening
the noose on mario paul the southern
city which has been under siege for
weeks now
the rescue operation at a theatre bombed
there on wednesday is still ongoing we
are told russians have targeted
civilians all over the city including
residential areas shopping centers and a
maternity hospital
intense fighting continues in the east
russia has tried to link its forces from
the north with those coming in from the
east authorities reported two people
killed in kramatorsk and one in kharkiv
this morning and explosions continued on
the outskirts of the capital this
morning with a residential area targeted
well speaking to sky news the mayor of
kiev said at least one person has been
killed several injured by that shelling
north of the capital
the emergency services say nearly a
hundred people were evacuated from
buildings our special correspondent alex
crawford is on the ground and spoke to
vitelli klitschko who was visiting the
site following that attack
one more fact
is the war against civilians i don't see
military people here
it's no military base
it's just apartments apartments from
civilians
against civilians
one one more example the russian
propaganda russians liar
what they explain about the some special
operation especially against ukrainian
military forces
this war against civilian against
ukraine ukrainian population how far do
you think in this period and we thought
that the negotiation was going well
because we had the progress do you think
that russians used this negotiation to
reorganize to delay and to reorganize
their army uh
i'm not involved i'm not involved and
that's why i
don't give a commenter for that
but
definitely negotiation and compromise
not
in the price of ukraine
we are not aggressive we are not
touch anyone we have aggressors in our
land
and the aggressors
killing our people which
compromise
which solution i don't know it's very
difficult uh question and that's why
i don't know it's uh
uh the question to the lesson
for the
if you look if you look in marijuana if
you look in harkett if you look in other
cities
right now
where the civilian will be destroyed the
city will be destroyed i expect
the russians do it exactly the same way
well let's bring in skies aleister
bunkel who's also in the view of
analysts are you woken by those
explosions uh at or near the airport
today tell us what you saw there
yeah i know the airaid sirens went off
around 6 15 in the morning that's become
pretty common for us here over the last
week or so but about 15 minutes later i
counted four explosions that's been
verified by authorities here six cruise
missiles fired from the black sea two of
them intercepted four of them landing
at an
airplane uh repair facility on the
airport complex we went to the airport
as all airport complexes are
they are secure perimeters it was very
hard to get anywhere close by uh
security officials here are really on
edge uh they don't want people getting
close to it they don't want the media
filming it and broadcasting it around
the world and doing any russian
propaganda or allowing the russians to
see what damage they did
but that building uh successfully
destroyed by the russians
no injuries no fatalities uh thankfully
but yet again a lever realizes that the
russians can and will strike deep into
ukrainian territory if they want to so
uh
you know we've we noticed that there was
an edge this morning if you like to to
people as they were as they were going
to work uh because of what happened last
night but they are determined the people
we spoke to are determined to crack on
with things they think they're winning
they think they will be victorious uh in
the end but
with the ground forces basically stalled
around some of the major cities i think
the tactic from the russians is now
pretty clear and that's what we
witnessed and that is using either
long-range uh precision guided missiles
or using
artillery at closer range that is
hitting civilian buildings and they
don't really seem to care about it
alastair thank you
well as the war in ukraine continues
civilians find themselves having to do
things that would previously seem
unthinkable sky news has met a family
who have managed to escape from mario
paul a city under siege facing sustained
shelling from russian forces
well john sparks spoke to the even offs
after they had managed to escape to the
city of dunipro
these cars form a convoy of sorts
a desperate procession of people who
have decided to flee
their residence of the port of mariopol
their home a city of death and despair
but it will require all their earthly
courage to leave it
in one do-it-yourself convoy the even
off family drive through the outskirts
of the city now controlled by the
russian military
father ivan is at the wheel
their son's fat sits in the back
his mother speaking for many evacuees
says life in mario paul isn't worth
living
having failed to capture this city the
russian military has decided to
pulverize it instead these pictures
taken with the even off family's camera
and the city's three-story theater has
been targeted in a strike this house of
culture serving as a refuge as the
russians encircled the city
there were hundreds of people sheltering
inside
crammed into the stalls and the
corridors these pictures taken in the
theater before the attack
the authorities say they are trying to
dig survivors out of the rubble
the drama theater was hit by
a russian strike
one thousand possibly one thousand two
hundred people taking shelter inside i
think it was
more
bigger
um
the city of mariopol was badly
unprepared says christina
there was nowhere to go few basements to
take shelter in
the family spent two weeks on the ground
floor of a local school
and they had no water and there was
little food to go around
foreign
with no services or power the residents
of mariopol are forced to make do
wooden cots from a kindergarten are
stripped for fuel
but it is a dangerous business spending
time outside in a city that suffers from
constant shelling
and it is difficult to bury the bodies
but it is
300 kilometers to the north
they couldn't bring their loved ones
with them their parents would not travel
but their nine-year-old boy is safe and
well
were there times where you felt scared
or frightened
continues to rage
although the russians claim they do not
target ukrainian towns and cities
but the even offs want the world to know
what they've been through
with
their home is more than 300 kilometers
from here but in a way they'll never
leave it
john sparks sky news in dinitro
well as we've heard from places like
mario paul they are very
short of food there's a real need to get
provisions out of places like where we
are in la vie to other parts of ukraine
and here is when many of these nations
come in that's a box of bread we think
from poland uh some crunchy dried fruit
as well from germany this is all oats
along here and all of this will be uh
distributed as i said to all of those
cities and towns that are in desperate
need flour huge bags of flour as well
remember we reported yesterday that a
food distribution center in kiev was
also hit it seems by a russian attack
camouflage as well this will be going to
the ukrainian forces on the border this
has been made by
volunteers in in large parts of the west
all of that will be sent out to the
front line effectively
water soft drinks all sorts of other
foods it gets very noisy because they're
packing all the time
yes about 250 vehicles a day leave this
site to get to other parts of ukraine
but we happen to meet here uh a man
would you believe from south end on c a
hotel manager what if i could grab a
quick chat with you this is michael j
paul uh michael
how long have you been here for why did
you decide to come
i've been here for about five days now
um i came
watching the news seeing all the kids
and the women and even the men
in distress
houses getting bombed hospitals getting
bombed i couldn't just sit back and
just watch it happen at least i'm here
trying to help
keep doing my part and
hopefully it's helping them
michael thank you very much indeed we're
going to leave you because vladimir
putin is about uh to give a speech this
is to commemorate the anniversary for
him of taking crimea
[Applause]
by when they went to the referendum in
sevastopol on the 18th of march in 2014
they lived and lived on their own
country and they wanted to
share the same destiny with their
historical motherland russia and they
had the full right to that and they
reached their purpose let us
congratulate first of all them on this
occasion it is their occasion
congratulations
[Applause]
fundamental nature
gas supplies
energy supplies
utilities
the restoration of roads
construction of new roads and motorways
and the bridges
we had to
bring up a crimea from that humiliating
situation state
where crimea and
found themselves
when they were part of another state and
which only financed crimea with the
remainder of their own
money
but we know what we should do now and
how we should do it
with
what we will implement
[Applause]
it's not just about those decisions
because what happened
on other territories
military operations against them and
more than one
and they were
surrounded
and they were
shelled from guns
they delivered airstrikes against them
the motive of our military operation
which we launched in
ukraine that's our purpose
and here i i think about the words from
the bible
there's no more love
for his friends
[Applause]
during this our guys during this
operation
they're chanting russia russia
it is slower there's worse
there's words
from the holy bible
our christian bible
what is
dear to people who profess this religion
the heart
of the matter is that this is a
universal value for all the people and
all the confessions of russia
and for our people first of all first of
all for our people
the best confirmation
and when it's necessary
we haven't had such unity in a long time
[Music]
of one of our
military
leaders
[Music]
[Applause]
forward russia forward russia
russia forward
so there was president putin then
hailing what he called the special
military operation here in ukraine at an
event to mark eight years since russia
annexed uh
crimea uh he also said that he liberated
crimea from a humiliating conditions
under ukraine well that war continues as
you can see this is donation of medical
devices to ukrainian ukrainian hospitals
looks like surgical items heading
towards hospitals uh east of where we
are it is having a devastating impact as
you know on the people of ukraine now
well here at this donation center in
levitt is a four-story building each
floor stacked with emergency supplies
including clothing medicine and toys
and it helps both those cities that are
in desperate need and also refugees
let's show you around
well if you have donated something from
the uk you may wonder what happens to it
it may well have ended up here it is an
aid redistribution center where some of
those who are displaced from other parts
of ukraine end up and try to restock
first of all they have to register so
let's take you through if we can uh
slightly fight our way in
uh this is a place that sees about
500 to 1000 people a day
many of them as you can see have been
again waiting quite a long time so this
mother and child come out there we go
so what happens here they straight away
they'll start registering little room
here this is an arts center in fact it
has exhibitions most of the time
set up very quickly to try to handle the
large numbers of people who are
desperate for
everything in fact
they will have left with just
a plastic bag possibly or a backpack
a wheelie bag and that is their life's
possessions inside
it's fairly chaotic as you can see
young children as well there is a room
for baby food
it's a tiring process isn't it natalie
it's busy today yes yes so that is easy
always busy always busy
natalie's one of the coordinators here
so registration desk as you can see
cups of coffee should they require it
and then this is over four floors and
really they've got absolutely everything
here from bedding which has been
packaged up and if you've donated
something as i said or a charity has or
even a national government it will come
here and they will completely sort it
out resort it package it into parcels to
take to people they'll come and get some
food first of all as you can see just to
well
a bit of sustenance having queued for
absolutely ages
uh let me talk to uh yuri pokovic
actually who is one of the lead
coordinators here
eureka i wonder if i can grab a word i
know you're very busy
when did this place actually open then
well this place opened three hours after
first bombing
and i was here on the second day and
what is it that you're trying to provide
for people here well we are trying to
provide the basic necessary stuff so
they can at least start rebuilding their
normal life as much as
possible so that's baby food in that
corner isn't it right yeah baby bedding
yeah some clothes and some because some
of the people just came here without
shoes on feet of their kids like fit uh
close with their sharks or their
sweaters around their kid's feet so we
try to at least find something that
would work for them and you're also
shipping stuff out to other parts of
ukraine that are in desperate need right
so we watch which have shipped
pre-interest leaks several trucks to
kharkiv
odessa mikulai person
also we are sending every day
dozens of
vans with staff and medicine food
closing and all the different aid we can
provide yuri thank you crucial work
thank you very much indeed to show you
the medicine shall we uh down here uh
this is some of the stuff that we'll be
going to you know those places he listed
there mikoliath
and what will happen is that the
different regions of ukraine and the
towns will write in to hear and say what
they need so if they need some of this
crucial medicine it'll be sorted and it
will be dispatched to them so this is
where they will get those items that
those towns and cities mainly in the
east and south of ukraine desperately
need
yes it really is a massive aid effort
but there are broad issues too for
example can relations with russia ever
return to normal again even if the war
in ukraine were to end tomorrow we'll be
discussing that after this break
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
well just a bit of breaking news we're
hearing that the prime minister boris
johnson has just come off the phone from
president zielinski uh the prime
minister reiterated his disgust at
russia's barbaric actions in ukraine and
his admiration we're told for these
steadfast resistance of the ukrainian
people in the face of tyranny he said
the entire united kingdom stands with
ukraine that's the very latest from
boris johnson the words he said to
president zielinski well certainly that
work continues as you can see that uh
resilience this is part of the bedding
that people have been donating and will
be taken to those in need here uh this
is all um things like sheets and
pillowcases that have been individually
bagged up so people can take them and as
you can see what a mammoth job it is
inside here where people are sorting
through
uh all of the stuff now many of this
stuff will have been donated by
individuals charities and in fact
national governments from europe so if
you donated something as i said before
this is very likely where it will end up
so it can be sorted through very
carefully and given to those people in
need both those who are displaced here
in ukraine and who are making their way
through to other parts of europe
now new data has shown that maritime
trade with russia as more than halved
since the invasion of ukraine began
three weeks ago one financial data
provider registered a 55 drop in ships
bound for russia since the end of
february it follows the imposition of a
series of damaging sanctions by western
countries but let's talk more joining me
now is aggressive vice president and
director for trade and global markets at
the progressive policy institute great
to have you on i mean you see the
massive task where we are here to deal
with the the fallout uh from russia's
invasion the other fallout of course is
the impact on russia so are these
sanctions beginning to bite
uh yeah i think they're beginning to
bite pretty hard uh we're hearing about
auto plants closing down we're hearing
about russia's banks being cut off from
financial flows russia being cut out of
the
international currency arrangements
the trade data don't come in the united
states to europe for several months
after it actually happens so what we
have now is anecdotal shots but this is
the largest and most coordinated
imposition of sanctions on any major
country um since
probably the 1950s um setting aside a
couple of small smaller cases of iraq
and iran so this is very significant and
it will have a big impact
yes we've seen um sanctions placed on
other countries like iran you know is
this significantly different and if so
will it have a very different impact as
well i mean what will the end result be
for russia
um well the end result ultimately
depends on the choices of the russian
government presumably but what we've had
now is a
you know a fairly coordinated set of
financial and trade and logistical and
personal sanctions on russia russia has
been cut off from most of the world's
financial flows
most of russia's major trading partners
have revoked their most favored nation
status we in the united states have
imposed import bans on energy and a
number of other products
but a lot of individual russian
business executives and government
officials have been personally
sanctioned
i have read that russia had about 600
billion dollars in foreign reserves put
aside
to prepare for an event like this and
they had lost
about 400 billion of those as they
placed them in western
financial institutions
so yes this is across the board this is
covering most aspects of the russian
economy
it
includes not only the united states uk
eu but also japan and korea
and a number of other asian and pacific
countries so it is
a remarkable
effort not only in the spectrum and
scope of the sanctions but in the
coordination across most of the world's
developed countries
the issue of course is by squeezing them
are we squeezing ourselves you know how
badly will we in the west be hit
i think it depends on where you live
we in the united states are not very
exposed to the russian economy
they make up about one percent of u.s
imports and about a third of a percent
of exports
so
u.s will have to do a bit of adjustment
we have to find some
alternate sources of palladium and of
fertilizer inputs and things like that
but those are very localized and not
systemic issues uk is a little bit more
exposed not very much the continental
europe is
reliant on russia obviously for energy
particularly for natural gas which is
hard to find from alternative sources so
continental europe will have to be
dealing with
the effects of
potential
russian
their electricity and power and that's a
big adjustment otherwise
russia will suffer uh us eu uk
asian countries not not nearly as much
still there back that much of that
yes edgar i was starting to vaguely lose
you there i do apologize just one quick
question if you don't mind if there is a
ceasefire how long should these
sanctions continue should they be
curtailed as an act of goodwill do you
think
um
hearing you
i'm not hearing you either i think we're
better
we
we better call it a ed grester thank you
very much indeed both of us are
struggling to hear each other from the
progressive policy institute
well let's get a little more on those
extraordinary pictures we just saw of
president putin
let's take you straight to aleister
bunkel reacting to those pictures
speaking to a large crowd in central
moscow
and this of course all to mark the
anniversary of crimea and you know we we
thought he was kind of stuck in his
bunker at the kremlin alistair didn't we
yeah i mean we've come used to seeing
president putin sitting one end of a
very long table and either uh his senior
security figures sitting the other end
or any foreign leaders who have visited
him we
have come used to him being paranoid
about catching coven and not wanting to
be close to anybody but now we see him
out and about uh at a stadium in moscow
with thousands of people waving the
russian flag to mark the capturing and
the annexation of crimea which happened
back in 2014. now look i i very much
doubt that it's by mistake by
coincidence that vladimir putin is being
seen to be out and about um as closed
off as he might be to much of the world
i'm sure he can't have failed to realize
that
continually sitting in a bunker gives
the impression of a bunker mentality and
so he wants to try and prove that the
russian people are behind him and behind
his what what he describes as the
special operation inside ukraine he's
been praising that operation saying that
it's going successfully but it is an
operation it is an invasion it is a war
that has so far yet failed to
comprehensively take and hold a city
they have failed to even encircle the
capital kiev they've failed to
unseat the government of president
zielinski they have lost four of their
major generals on the front line plus
thousands of other troops and a lot of
equipment as well and this was supposed
to be one of the most fearsome one of
the most powerful military forces in the
world so
the facts bear out the operation the
conflict the invasion is not going well
for russia at all the ukraines are
putting up a resistance and
president putin's given no indication
that he's necessarily aware of that but
one assumes that he must be but this
message is a message for his people he
has shut down much of independent media
within russia he shut down access to
foreign media social media and so this
is the message this is the spin that
he's putting on the conflict to the
russian people
alastair updating us there thank you
very much indeed so joe biden speaking
to xi jinping the big question can china
be persuaded to use its influence over
russia's president vladimir putin back
with that after this
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it was everything that a journalist
might want in a story a story that you'd
be proud to have filmed
that they didn't want journalists to see
the real story
it was very tiring it was very sad it
was very scary at times there's no need
for this but you have to keep going
look at that
you don't want to lecture people but you
do have to give them the fact
i'm david blevins and i'm skye's senior
ireland correspondent
i'm based in belfast the city
transformed by peace but still
struggling with its past
now the u.s president joe biden is
currently on a call with his chinese
counterpart xi jinping among other
things joe biden is expected to push for
xi not to help russia in its military
operation in ukraine well joining me now
is robert daley former diplomat at the
u.s embassy in beijing and director of
the wilson center's kissinger institute
on china and the united states thanks
very much indeed for joining us um first
direct talks understand since november
so what does america need to tell to
china
president biden will tell president xi
that if he supports russia either
through uh providing military equipment
or helping it evade sanctions that there
will be a serious price to pay
for china so he is going to essentially
uh threaten and cajole xi jinping and at
the same time we'll be trying to
encourage him to use his offices
to temper russia's actions the problem
is if you threaten and cajole china in
the same meeting uh china tends to feel
more threatened than cajoled and it will
bite back
now your view i've seen from from what
you've tweeted is that china is too tied
into the global economy to risk helping
russia problem is that as it presumes we
are up for punishing them if they do
exactly so we are we are threatening
china essentially with secondary
sanctions but any secondary sanctions
that we imposed that china would feel
we and by we i mean the rest of the
world including the united states would
also feel heavily because we're very
integrated and so the broad context for
the xi uh biden meeting is is the united
states uh going to remain integrated
with china is china going to remain
integrated with europe and and with the
west so there's both the narrow question
about ukraine and what china does or
doesn't do and the broader question
about china's relations with the rest of
the world and whether decoupling will
continue so there are several layers to
this discussion
they try to as you know uh you know
follow a neutral path haven't they um
but do you do you think diplomatic
tightrope walkers eventually fall off
and which way if they do will they fall
if china feels that it has to fall one
way or the other then china stands with
russia it has already made that clear
and china made a decision during the
first year of the biden administration
which disappointed them in many ways
they were hoping for a rollback of the
trump policy toward china and they
didn't get it china has made a decision
that the united states
does wish to contain china that really
our china policy is one of
regime change and so china will
defensively stand with russia but it
will maintain the fiction of neutrality
for as long as it can and even if the
united states and much of the rest of
the world says to china you clearly
stand with russia they will continue to
say to their own people to themselves to
the world no
we are neutral we are impartial we stand
for peace
how do you help us understand how the
chinese actually think you know are they
looking at the the new world order you
know closer partnership with russia or
do you think the chinese people and
indeed the chinese government actually
have some sympathy with the people here
in ukraine who are suffering so badly in
many places
well first i think there's a great deal
of sympathy for the people in ukraine we
have to remember that china has and has
had for a while a good relationship with
ukraine they buy a lot of corn and wheat
from ukraine their belt and road
infrastructure projects go through
ukraine china's one operative aircraft
carrier is a second-hand uh purchase
from ukraine the people of china of
course aren't hearing a lot of what
we're hearing in the west they're not
seeing the footage
china controls that but there is
certainly sympathy from the chinese
people uh for people in ukraine how the
government sees this is a different
question the master narrative is that
the west is in decline and the east is
rising so china sees the trend lines as
being in its favor it thinks the
american-led west is clinging to what
remains of its hegemony in a dangerous
and deluded way and so they are playing
uh the longer game and in that ukraine
is a piece but only a piece so they're
not hyper focused on it the way that we
are in the west
well it's fascinating geopolitics at the
highest level isn't it robert daley
thank you very much indeed thank you now
we've just had a statement from the
ukrainian president vladimir zelinski
let's listen in
islam
the unbreakable country this is day 23
of our patriotic war after eight years
of the war in the east the occupiers
keep
burned their national
wealth
on the war in ukraine they will
destroy everything that russian society
has reached over the past 25 years and
they will return
where they begin to rise into the
into the
90s only after
hopes of millions of people to
work for the development of their
country
so this will be the result of the war
against ricket this will be a painful
fall and they feel that
even
even against the opium for the people
delivered by
propaganda peddlers wars are always
expensive especially
the price is high for the aggressor but
whatever happens this will not uh
resurrect our dead people it will not uh
rebuild our cities and it will not erase
the
pain in our hearts that will always
remain
i have no doubt we will build everything
will become a full member of the united
nations each representative of our
country works on that 24 7 but life will
have changed forever
because of so many hearts that have
stopped because of this war
eternal memory for all those who have
given their life for ukraine the russian
troops
continued
pounding our peaceful communities and
and sounds uh
the sounds of
donbass
missile
strikes and aviation bombs we try to
shoot them down as much as we can we
destroy their planes we destroy their
helicopters
accounting for the fact that we still
don't have
uh adequate
ansi
advanced weapons we don't have enough
fighter planes but our plane is to
defend our people our country
and we will continue everything we
can
leaders that it will be a moral reproach
to them it will make them ashamed that
ukraine hasn't
received the advanced weapons that it
needs to defend
thousands of of the lives of our people
i have a lot of
negotiations so they
they're lying jacqueline michelle the
chairman of the european council
john johnson our great friend the agenda
is understandable of course it's the
concrete steps which will give ukraine
more
force but also for the economy and for
uh the ukrainians who are now and and
here are defending europe on our land
promised to do everything she can to
expedite the process of ukraine joining
the eu the processes that normally take
years it will be shortened for our
country to weeks and months it's not
easy but we will do that we have also
agreed that we will receive support uh
from the eu for the ukrainians who have
to leave their countries because of the
war
those who are abroad and inside our
country we have also
agreed on another 300 million uh
euro
for ukraine uh on top of what has been
agreed before we have will also
discuss a new sanctions against russia
so that they will feel that each missile
against our state each bomb each uh
shorts has a price and for the russian
budget for russian companies for russian
ambitions and force
individuals russian individuals who
represent the russian authorities and
until ukraine has peace
the sanctions against russia
have to become stronger and for
and for the people who propose that
that
restrictions should be
restricted not just for the country but
also for certain uh communities and the
swedish dockers refused to service
russian ships and everybody should
follow this example all communities and
trade associations if we don't stop
russia now if we don't punish russia now
other aggressors in the world will start
other wars in other regions on other
continents everywhere where this or that
country hopes to subjugate their
neighbors we have to act now so that
any potential aggressors can see that
was only bring losses and no profits so
that it's necessary that all europeans
should block ports for all russian ships
that all russian commercial ships
will be
will follow that russian that proverbial
russian military ship
all western
companies should leave the russian
market and shouldn't use pr cheap
to cover up
their money for work crimes like
ocean or nestle are doing
we have a great humanitarian corridors
in several regions
suma
uh
and it's very difficult to arrange
corridor from uh
mariupol to the pakistan the occupy is
doing everything to stop a humanitarian
ukrainian
humanitarian conveys to the city this is
terror we are doing everything we can we
have also rescued 35 000 people from
marijuana we continue rescue work at the
site of the uh blown up theater
the
we have in total saved 130
people but
much more people are still under the
rubble and we will continue rescue work
the situation is very difficult
in hiking region the occupiers continue
trying to destroy our city of issue
i turned to people in balaclava our team
is doing everything to set up an active
humanitarian corridor to those towns and
to deliver water
food and medications i have instructed
the cabinets and the speaker of the
parliament to create such a
format for decisions so that it can
provide
all the necessary goods from abroad
such as fuel food and all the other
goods that
will
answer to the basic needs of society
this is no time for bureaucrats and
ambitious people
stop and benefit from the needs of the
people we will speed up customs
clearance of all the goods that are so
needed for ukrainians if we have to
we have to
tax those
goods
customers uh customs officials then
we'll do that our borders must be open
to everything that's needed for
ukrainians i expect
adequate decisions until the end of
today and also the then the answer from
memphis because everybody has to work
today only for ukraine
for
uh our country and people not for their
own ambitions and for bureaucracy
everything has to be focused on the
defense of ukraine i have signed um
order to to award
state awards to 138
because of his resolute actions
losses were inflicted on the enemy since
the beginning of the
defense of kiev more than 30 towns were
released
liberated
outside cave
he inflicted tangible losses to the
enemy and stopped
its
advance
an order for courage is awarded to uh
a
senior
medic she took part in in saving
the wounded from uh
marijuana thanks to her
actions
31
troops were saved
she continues working in marijuana
glory to all our heroes glory to
ukraine well vladimir zelinski they're
talking about the needs of the ukrainian
people including in places like mariupol
25 000 people he said had been freed
from there and talking about that
theater which we know was bombed 130
have been rescued and it is in this
place that those needs are being met
including as you can see for children
the toys that people like you at home
have donated end up here and they are
distributed throughout ukraine and for
refugees who are fleeing and certainly
we know that the movement of people
towards the polish border has slowed it
was about a hundred thousand a day it's
now dropped to fifty thousand a day but
that's still huge numbers of people
let's take you in here to another
auditorium this is where they've been
gathering and uh sourcing clothes again
for children especially warm ones it's
been really cold for people hats gloves
socks all gathered here all sorted and
boxed up and all of these people are
working 24 7 trying to make sure people
get the things they need vladimir
zelinski's saying they're also working
24 72 to become a member of the european
union the dream of nato membership by
might end but not that dream of being a
member of the european union so
displaced people uh now three and a
quarter million have departed two
million million extra are displaced in
ukraine itself and in places like here
they're trying to provide food
sustenance clothing bedding everything
they need to try to rebuild their life
which has been so badly damaged by that
russian invasion which began
three weeks ago
our coverage continues of course coming
up in the next hour beldanata will take
you through all of today's news from
levitt we'll see you later
well as anna said this is kind news the
top stories at 2 p.m
kiev under attack another fatal shelling
in the capital with the mayor telling
sky news that attacks on civilians are
deliberate
how many mistakes they do it how many
children have to kill and after that to
explain about mistake
construction and devastation in mario
paul as 130 survivors are pulled from
the rubble of a bombed theatre in the
city
meanwhile in moscow president